happy
Wednesday
my goodness so I guess we should talk
about Liz Cheney
the lady who puts the Y in Wyoming and
the ing in losing
slide to a trump back candidate Harriet
Hageman sounds about right she got
creamed by 30 plus points on the bright
side she's still more popular than
monkey pox
and she no longer has to pretend that
she lives in Wyoming
of Liz's concession speech
[Music]
she really puts the Liz in lizard
here's the real stuff
two years ago I won this primary with 73
percent of the votes
I could easily have done the same again
the path was clear
but it would have required that I go
along with President Trump's lie about
the 2020 election it would have required
that I enable his ongoing efforts to
unravel our democratic system and attack
the foundations of our Republic
that was a path I could not and would
not take
that Podium has more charm I mean she's
really I didn't realize how boring she
was until we started doing stories on
her yeah it's all about a threat to
democracy you know maybe someone should
tell Liz she was voted out
that's democracy
[Applause]
prepare herself to the great and
original champion of our party Abraham
Lincoln
the great and original champion of our
party Abraham Lincoln was defeated in
elections for the Senate and the house
before he won the most important
election of all
Lincoln ultimately prevailed he saved
our Union and he defined Our obligation
as Americans for all of history
it's just the ego on this lady isn't who
does she think she is
I'm
forgot
[Music]
funny because it's true
but Liz and Abe do have one thing in
common their love for theater did them
in
[Laughter]
talk about a drama queen she then
compared all of this to the Civil War
you know I wonder if she will continue
this battle
I am absolutely going to continue this
battle I think it's the most important
thing I've ever been involved in and I
think it's it's certainly the most
important thing challenge that our
nation has faced in recent history uh
and maybe since the Civil War and and
it's one that we must win
say General Lee
you ain't even Sara Lee
she sees herself as Ulysses S Grant but
she never will be her mustache just
isn't thick enough
I said it isn't I said it isn't but
let's hope if she is ever a wartime
president her troops have better aim
than her father
because he he shot somebody in the face
if you don't know but man even her
metaphors her metaphors are linked to
war she sure seems obsessed with it what
did someone sink her Battleship when she
was a kid
you know there's nothing stopping you
from moving to Ukraine Liz
but will she run for president I bet
that's a decision she's going to make in
the coming months that's a decision that
I'm going to make in the in the coming
months Savannah I'm not going to make
any announcements here this morning but
uh but it is something that I I'm
thinking about
if she wins it will be the first time in
U.S history that a father and daughter
both held office pres as president
[Laughter]
how delusional is she
she's a Republican and Republicans hate
her more than they hate children
people in it and 79 of them are
Republican would be assigned to anybody
in the GOP that they should seek the
presidency she had better luck opening a
trump gift shop at Mar-A-Lago
that would be great but she's not
listening to the electorate she's
listening to the media who are egging
her on again exploiting her trumped
Arrangement they actually convinced her
to lose
which is easy when you carry a personal
emotional Vendetta Cheney hates Trump
because he had no use for her or her
Wars he viewed such Endeavors as a waste
of blood and treasure and you can argue
both sides but history seems to back
Trump the Iraq War was a disaster based
on a big lie Afghanistan well like the
skin on Pelosi's face stretched Beyond
its purpose
so cheap
terrible Don't Clap that's terrible
nation building nation building is a lot
like Dick Cheney's heart it doesn't work
and there's lots of surprise attacks
for the longest time Libs considered the
Cheney's the epitome of evil they made
movies about them you know like Tootsie
the media considered dick a warmonger
and she a chip off the old blocked
artery
but then something happened the left in
the media found a villain more evil than
warmongers Trump who's not one so
Democrats lavished lives with praise it
was like she had faked a hate crime
oh I could read you all the tweets from
last night from the fawning press but
this summarizes it best
[Music]
they returned
yeah so even though Liz was considered
by the left to be a war criminal
and Trump by comparison a fast a
pacifist he's somehow worse politics
makes strange bedfellows but so does a
trip to sandals with Brian Kilmeade
so now if you suffending others to
useless Wars you'd never fight in you're
a real hero as long as you hate Trump
but all those praising her it's the same
voices made irrelevant when public
sentiment left them behind they portray
her as a selfless Warrior battling
orange Hitler but you see through that
you see that this is all personal the
January 6th show trial revealed that
like a blind guy playing poker she
showed her cards this is not some
principled stance it's obsessive Revenge
Hell hath no fury like a Cheney woman
scorned and her dad will have to
waterboard me to say otherwise
kind of looking forward to it
the fact is the voters chose Trump
sensing the cheneys had their run and
they did the voters also made quick work
of Jeb Bush like George Conway gobbling
up cobbler
the party has changed it's gotten more
interesting it's gotten more fun more
unpredictable the way a Fox News party
does when Cat shows up with a bottle of
tequila and two friends she met on
Grindr
the Republican party is no longer a
bunch of millionaires getting rich off
their families playing risk with other
people's lives today we see more keen on
preserving the lives of those who pledge
to defend this country Young Americans
should need five deferments to avoid
fighting a useless war in another
country so maybe Liz's loss is a win for
those who don't fit that bill and that's
not just Donald Trump it might be you
too guess you could say we dodged a
bullet
welcome
tonight's guest she's so perky she can
brew coffee without a pot outnumbered
co-host Emily campagno
and nothing can stop him except a really
strong magnet retired Marine Corps bomb
technician Johnny Joey toad
he knows how to draw a crowd on paper
with crayons writer and comedian Joe
DeVito
all right
Ed sees the reason liquor stores have
security cameras Foxy's contributor cat
two
Emily don't you feel like you're
watching like a personal Vendetta being
like exercised and like public and it's
like she's the January 6 committee this
election it's all about she says it's
about the big lie but the big lie is
that she's denying it's actually her
personal feelings it's like that movie
He's Just Not That Into You or your
girlfriend will not stop obsessing over
how it it actually would work out and
she it should be her and she is all that
because everything coming out of her
mouth is so it's so stale it's so
delusional she reminds me frankly of a
Democrat where everything is about
Donald Trump she said the main priority
was to defeat his election in the future
she's really parodying what we heard in
2016. and she said that she would have
won in a landslide that same 30-point
resounding defeat that she enjoyed she
says that it would have been overturned
if she or it would have been um you know
she would have enjoyed the win if
everyone had the same priorities she did
Right But the irony and the whole point
is that she's not seeing the party as
you described it which is that it's
diverse it's fresh and I think all you
have to do is look what Americans are
doing Hispanics African-Americans are
flocking to the Republican Party
Independents are flocking to the GOP so
are students as well because they have
the same priorities that she doesn't
right which is putting food on the table
inflation the economy crime but hers was
about January 6th exactly all the way
she never said anything about anything
else exactly Joey do you do you sense
that this is a turning point in the
sense that uh like they're turning it
into the end of democracy in Civil War
but really it's about looking back at a
party that's changed and that has moved
on I mean you are veteran of Wars
obviously is what do you think of this a
couple of them actually a couple of
words that veteran of the the Iraq War
the Afghanistan war and then the war at
Walter Reed trying to get out of there
alive yeah but no seriously if you think
about you know you brought up a good
point she said that uh she said she
would have won in a landslide if well
guess what somebody did win that
election in a landslide yes and why did
why did she win that election Landslide
because she talked about things that
people in Wyoming care about that I
don't know if they're wyomens or Wyoming
some say people from Wyoming completely
correct she it's not about Trump we call
him wyomis what like my homies like
you're my homies you're my you're my
Wyoming
[Laughter]
but in this case but in this case I'm
the one who cut you off
and on the knees oh okay he started it
Greg's just mad because I don't have
legs I'm still taller with them all
[Applause]
this this is the problem with Liz Cheney
how long did it take us to care about
something else
[Laughter]
right you know maybe like she got it's
really weird when you see people change
and when they and they can't see it
themselves right I was like this for a
bit you know in 2015 I was like but then
it's like we have to step out and go
okay I'm getting really emotional about
something I shouldn't be emotional about
and I think that's like and it's like
you see that with kinzinger you see that
with her you see that with a lot of
people with her kids two different
situations with kinsinger you know he's
right outside Chicago he's going to lose
that seat anyway yeah he grabbed a hold
of whatever cell he thought would have
wind in it yeah but with her she is she
cannot understand and she is so mad that
everyone else isn't mad about what she's
mad exactly exactly so Joe do you think
uh do you think Liz is a modern day Abe
Lincoln yes the the main thing they have
in common is that neither of them is
going to be president anytime
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and she she did have that awesome log
Podium that was very good
I think it was her slogan
um vote for me or my dad will shoot you
in the face
that resonated but it's amazing again
you talk about the ego she loses by 30
points and thinks time to take this
Nationwide right that's right that's
strange even the team that loses to the
Harlem Globetrotters doesn't think it's
time for bigger and better opportunities
time for the Olympics yeah so yeah
you're right she is obsessed because she
doesn't even understand her own party
right the people who oppose this they
don't realize it it's the ego's
incredible they say well why don't you
vote for me I'm awesome can't you see
that you stupid ignorant people and if
you have to think that after you lose
maybe you weren't that awesome so people
want something other than people who
treat our government as their family
business and that's why she is now out
of business hopefully forever yeah it's
a great place
cat
cat I suppose I suppose you feel a bit
Vindicated over this yeah I mean it's
just so weird seeing somebody play
martyr who ha everything she has she
owes to war profiteering like her and
she had her dad doing ads for her about
it was so proud of the the truth and
it's like because of the lies of her dad
that she peddled herself people died
people have PTSD people are severely
injured and she gets to be at like so
brave because it's easy to be brave when
you have millions and millions and
millions of your daddy's blood money to
fall back on Good Riddance I mean some
of us got a pretty good career
yeah and for you the military was just a
jumping off point too yeah the gut felt
it was a very explosive stepping stone
[Laughter]
you know you know I'm not even this
I'm just gonna go to the t's
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else